Hey everybody, this is SmartLess, it's a podcast with Jason Bateman, Will Arnett, and myself, Sean Hayes, and we, the, how the show works is there, there's a person that comes, like a guest that comes out. Well, one of us acts as a host. Slow down, slow down, man. I just feel, I just feel like you got a lot of like extra energy today and you just all, you're, you're all over the map. Just, okay, let me just finish then. So there's somebody comes, one of us acts as like the host and brings on somebody that the other two don't know about, like something like that. Yeah, that's great.
大家好，这里是SmartLess，这是一档由杰森·贝特曼、威尔·阿奈特和我肖恩·海耶斯主持的播客。节目的形式是这样的，会有一位嘉宾来到现场。嗯，我们其中一个人担任主持人。慢点，慢点，伙计。我只是觉得，我只是觉得你今天精力过剩，而且你有点语无伦次。好吧，让我说完。所以会有人来，我们其中一个人担任主持人，带上一位另外两人都不知道的嘉宾，大概就是这样。是的，那太棒了。
So it's a surprise, it's a surprise. Just, just say that, man. All right, or just listen to another episode. Hey, do you guys, you know, I'm doing my own laundry more often and a lot of times I'll forget like it's in there and it's got to be like, can you get the laundry and I'll forget it's in the dryer. So I have to fluff it up for like 20 minutes, like a half hour. So you can, so it's not so wrinkly, but then I forget to get it again. So then I have to the next day, do it again. Do you guys do that? You're becoming a fluffer is what you're saying.
所以这是一个惊喜，这是一个惊喜。就，就直说吧，伙计。好吧，或者去听另一集。嘿，你们，你们知道吗，我最近更频繁地自己洗衣服了，很多时候我会忘记衣服还在洗衣机里，然后就得像，你能去拿一下衣服吗，但我又忘了它还在烘干机里。所以我得把它再烘个20分钟，半小时左右。这样它就不会那么皱了，但我又忘了去拿。所以第二天我不得不又做一遍。你们会这样吗？你是说你正在变成一个“蓬松处理员”。
I think that's basically, that's the headline right there. We got it. It's better than leaving your wash in the washer because then it smells like mold and shit. Yeah. And then you got to rewash it and that's a smell by the way, hang on, this is perfect for you, Will, you dirty hockey playing Canadian. There's a smell to hockey gear that is like clothes left in a washing machine that for some reason you guys get used to. How do you get used to that smell? I had to come in the side door with my hockey bag and it had to go straight down to the basement to the boiler room where the heater was because it couldn't be my mom's, it can't
我想这基本上就是标题了。我们抓住了重点。这总比把洗好的衣服留在洗衣机里好，因为那样会有一股霉味和臭味。是的。然后你还得重洗，顺便说一句，这味道，等等，这太适合你了，威尔，你这个肮脏的打曲棍球的加拿大人。曲棍球装备有一种味道，就像留在洗衣机里的衣服，不知为何你们习惯了。你们是怎么习惯那种味道的？我得带着我的曲棍球包从侧门进来，然后直接把它扔到地下室的锅炉房，那里有加热器，因为它不能和我妈的，它不能
be in a room with anything else other than the fucking, but it doesn't bother you though. It doesn't bother their hockey players. That's how do you get used to that? Cause it's a sense memory reminds you of the rink. You're rotten. It's reminds of the rink. Yeah. It does. But it also reminds me of camaraderie. It reminds me of being part of a team, being some part of something where I'm not just thinking about myself. It smells like an ass. Okay. Well, let me also just say this. I love listening to you two guys who don't do laundry on the reg, discussing how, oh
和任何其他东西放在同一个房间里，除了该死的，但这并不困扰你。这不会困扰曲棍球运动员。你们是怎么习惯的？因为这是一种感官记忆，让你想起溜冰场。你烂透了。它让我想起溜冰场。是的。确实。但它也让我想起友情。它让我想起成为团队的一部分，成为某种东西的一部分，而不只是考虑我自己。闻起来像屁股。好吧。嗯，让我再说一点。我喜欢听你们两个平时不洗衣服的家伙讨论如何，哦
when you're out there just pinning stuff up on the line, right? Yeah, that's fair. Did I mention the magic people? Yeah, you got a team of them. All right. So let's, let's get on with the show. We've probably got an inpatient guest waiting. So this girl that we have on today is extraordinary. She kind of came on the scene like a thunderbolt and she's the first Asian-American who won a golden globe award for best actress. One of the funniest people out there today. A brilliant, brilliant actor. Yeah, we're going to see. It's Aquafina, everybody.
当你把东西挂在绳子上的时候，对吧？是的，这很公平。我提到那些神奇的人了吗？是的，你有一支他们的团队。好吧。那么，让我们继续节目吧。我们可能有一位不耐烦的嘉宾在等着。今天来的这位女孩非常了不起。她像一道闪电一样出现在舞台上，她是第一位获得金球奖最佳女主角的亚裔美国人。当今最有趣的人之一。一位才华横溢、才华横溢的演员。是的，我们要见到了。大家欢迎奥卡菲娜。
Oh, Aquafina. Hi, what's up? Well, listen, Aquafina, I wanted to have you on not only because I'm such a huge, huge, huge fan, but you're one of those people. And so are we, Will. Yes, so we all are. He's so rude. But you know, you know the premise of the show that each one of us, each episode acts as the host and we bring on a surprise guest. So I wanted you on, but we just all happen to be fans. But and you came on to the scene in such a huge way. I mean, your voice, your comedy, your attitude, all the stuff that you do, it's so fresh and
哦，奥卡菲娜。嗨，你好吗？嗯，听着，奥卡菲娜，我想请你来不仅是因为我是你超级、超级、超级大的粉丝，而且你是那种人。我们也是，威尔。是的，我们都是。他太粗鲁了。但你知道，你知道节目的前提，我们每个人，每一集都担任主持人，我们带上一位惊喜嘉宾。所以我想要你来，但我们恰好都是你的粉丝。但是你以如此巨大的方式出现在舞台上。我是说，你的声音，你的喜剧，你的态度，你所做的一切，它是如此新鲜，而且
nobody's really kind of, you know, you just, it's just a breath of fresh air is in the, on the comedy scene. And I'm like one of the many who are like, who is this girl? Where does she come from? She's brilliant. But because from where I said, it all happened overnight, but we all know it took 12 years to become an overnight success. But is that how it feels for you? Or were you like, Jesus, God, it's about time. Yeah, that's, no, that's exactly how it feels. It felt like it happened overnight. And I think with that came a lot of other things, you know, like, it's not late, you know what I mean? Like, like it's not like, I think there's a lot of anxiety, a lot of self-doubt,
没有人真的，你知道，你只是，你是喜剧界的一股清风。我像许多人一样，心想，这个女孩是谁？她从哪里来？她太棒了。但从我的角度来看，这一切似乎是一夜之间发生的，但我们都知道，成为一夜成名的成功人士花了12年。但对你来说是这种感觉吗？还是你觉得，天哪，上帝，终于到了？是的，那，不，那正是这种感觉。感觉就像是一夜之间发生的。我想随之而来的是很多其他事情，你知道，就像，这并不晚，你明白我的意思吗？就像，就像，我想有很多焦虑，很多自我怀疑，
you know, been postures, like there's so much. Yeah, because you're kind of one of the, you're a quintessential example of a YouTube star. Yeah. Who got her, her fame and, and notice from YouTube and then transferred over to this massive Hollywood, brilliant actor. Is that true? So, so that was your first sort of foray was through self-generated, like stuff that you did? Yeah, yeah. I put out a video called My Vage when I was like, back in 2011. And it was an answer to my dick, right? My dick. Mickey Avalon's my dick. Yeah.
你知道，冒充者综合症，有很多。是的，因为你算是，你是YouTube明星的典型例子。是的。她从YouTube上获得了名声和关注，然后转到了这个巨大的好莱坞，才华横溢的演员。是真的吗？所以，那是你第一次尝试是通过你自己制作的东西？是的，是的。我在2011年的时候发布了一个叫《My Vag》的视频。那是对《My Dick》的回应，对吧？《My Dick》。米奇·阿瓦隆的《My Dick》。是的。
Can you give dum-dums like me a little refresher on what YouTube is? Is that, is that two words or is it one word? Oh, geez, that was so sweet. And Jason, Jason, the light's on on your phone. You keep switching the light on on your phone. He's so old. No, he is. So first of all, tell me about My Vage and then also what, what is a, what is a Vage? Is that a car? What is a Vage? Is that, is it a pet or is it, how do you spell it? It's a V-A-G. Uh-huh. So that's an acronym for?
你能给像我这样的笨蛋简单复习一下什么是YouTube吗？那是，那是两个词还是一个词？哦，天哪，那太可爱了。还有杰森，杰森，你手机上的灯亮着。你一直在打开手机上的灯。他太老了。不，他是。所以首先，告诉我关于《My Vag》的事，还有什么是，什么是Vag？那是一辆车吗？什么是Vag？那是，它是一个宠物还是，你怎么拼写它？是V-A-G。嗯哼。所以那是什么的缩写？
Because it's a nickname. No, I know it a badger. So how, so is that a, was it a song? Was it a? It was a, yeah, it was a song. I, I started out as a rapper. So I, I did that one and got fired from my job because she, she had asked like what I did on my birthday and I told her I made a music video. And at that point she thought I was like this very meek assistant, which I was. And what kind of job assistant for what? It was for a, a, a, a seminary, a book club. A book club? Like a publisher. Um, yeah.
因为那是一个昵称。不，我知道它是一个獾。所以，所以那是一个，它是一首歌吗？它是一个？它是一个，是的，它是一首歌。我，我最初是一名说唱歌手。所以我，我做了那个，然后被我的工作解雇了，因为她，她问我生日那天做了什么，我告诉她我制作了一个音乐视频。在那一点上，她认为我是一个非常温顺的助理，我确实是。那是什么样的工作，什么助理？那是为一个，一个，一个，一个神学院，一个读书俱乐部。读书俱乐部？像出版商。嗯，是的。
Okay. Yeah. In New York? In New York. And she fired you. Not a progressive publisher, I'm assuming. Yeah. I mean, they don't exist anymore. So like who cares? But, um, it was, I was also like a shitty assistant, you know. But I think it was the name of what it was called.
好的。是的。在纽约？在纽约。然后她解雇了你。我假设不是一个进步的出版商。是的。我是说，它们现在不存在了。所以谁在乎呢？但是，嗯，我也是一个糟糕的助理，你知道。但我认为那是它名字的由来。
And she was like, be careful what you put on the internet. Uh-huh. You're like, no worries. I'm just putting out a video called My Vag. Yeah, I'll be fine with visuals. Yeah. Do you ever want to go back to being an assistant and just nail it? Yes and no.
然后她说，小心你在互联网上放什么。嗯哼。你就像，不用担心。我只是发布了一个叫《My Vag》的视频。是的，我会没事的，有视觉效果。是的。你有没有想过回去当助理，然后把它做好？想，也不想。
I still don't have closure from being part of my job. I like it's like for real. No, but like you are, you're a very successful rapper. Like you sell albums and your YouTube rapping videos, like millions of people watch. I mean, it's crazy. Yeah. God damn it, I feel old.
我仍然没有从我的工作中得到解脱。我喜欢它，就像是真的。不，但是你，你是一个非常成功的说唱歌手。你卖专辑，你的YouTube说唱视频，数百万人观看。我是说，这太疯狂了。是的。该死的，我觉得我老了。
Again, sorry. The YouTube, this is a, is it a TV? The YouTube, um, yeah, it's kind of like a TV. Yeah, within a computer. I gotta get, I gotta get up on the rap. Yeah, man. Damn it. You gotta download it.
再次，抱歉。YouTube，这是一个，它是一个电视吗？YouTube，嗯，是的，它有点像电视。是的，在电脑里面。我得，我得赶上说唱。是的，伙计。该死的。你得下载它。
You went from Nora Lum, which is your name, to Aquafina. Yes. And I know you're sick of talking about it, where the name come from, blah, blah, blah. And you hate people comparing it to bottled water, because that's a dumb joke. So we'll, we'll, we'll do that one later. He's working on it right now.
你从诺拉·卢姆，也就是你的名字，变成了奥卡菲娜。是的。我知道你厌倦了谈论它，名字从哪里来，等等等等。而且你讨厌人们把它和瓶装水比较，因为那是一个愚蠢的笑话。所以我们，我们，我们稍后再做那个。他现在正在努力。
Why, wait, why have we designated me for that? I didn't even think about that old man. Again, you guys are so old. I'm way too young and hip. Wait, so Nora, Nora from Queens. What's the name of the show you're on? Grew up in Queens. Grew up in Queens.
为什么，等等，为什么我们指定我做那个？我甚至没想过那个老头。再说一次，你们太老了。我太年轻和时髦了。等等，所以诺拉，来自皇后区的诺拉。你参加的节目叫什么名字？在皇后区长大。在皇后区长大。
Yeah. For reals. Okay. So Grew up in Queens. Born in Stony Brook, actually. Born in Stony Brook. Okay. Hey, hey, hey, Canada, Canada.
是的。真的。好的。所以，在皇后区长大。其实出生在石溪。出生在石溪。好的。嘿，嘿，嘿，加拿大，加拿大。
Try not to bond, don't bond with her over Stony Brook, okay? Hey, chill. I lived in New York for over 20 years. So I'm all right. I'm okay. So let me ask you this. So did you go to performing arts high school in New York? Yes.
尽量不要建立联系，不要因为石溪和她建立联系，好吗？嘿，冷静。我在纽约住了20多年。所以我很好。我没事。所以让我问你这个。所以你去了纽约的表演艺术高中吗？是的。
You did? Yes. I thought I heard that. I thought I heard that rumor. Oh, cool. And how was that experience? It was good. I mean, I wasn't a good student.
你去了？是的。我想我听到了。我想我听到了那个传闻。哦，酷。那次经历怎么样？很好。我是说，我不是一个好学生。
I think, like, I played the trumpet, you know, and I think, I just didn't have the moxie for the trumpet, you know, like I was, you know, I just. Was that the track that you were on? Was it, was it a music, uh, uh. The trumpet track? Yeah. I don't even know what that track looks like.
我想，就像，我吹小号，你知道，我想，我只是没有吹小号的勇气，你知道，就像我，你知道，我只是。那是你在走的轨道吗？它是，它是一个音乐，呃，呃。小号轨道？是的。我甚至不知道那个轨道看起来是什么样的。
I don't, I don't know why. I don't know what I was thinking. A lot of world beaters come out of that program. I think when you take the trumpet, I think that first year you just learned, and then second year they teach you how to be a junkie, don't they? Isn't that part of it?
我不知道，我不知道我在想什么。很多世界级的人才都是从那个项目中出来的。我想当你选择小号时，我想第一年你只是学习，然后第二年他们教你如何成为一个瘾君子，不是吗？那不是它的一部分吗？
Really? You have to, yeah, like Chet Baker, you just have to be coming junkie. Right, right, for sure. And it's tough. Because I think that that's, you know, it's hard to imagine, uh, where one goes with that, but, um, that's what I, that's what I loved.
真的吗？你必须，是的，就像切特·贝克，你只需要成为一个瘾君子。对，对，当然。而且这很难。因为我认为那是，你知道，很难想象，呃，一个人会走向何方，但是，嗯，那是我，那是我喜欢的。
Yeah, how did that, were you, were you working at the publishing house during that, or, um, or doing any other rapping yet? At that time, um, like in high school, or? That was in high school. Well, you know, you start, well, I started working at 10, I apologize. Yeah, yeah, so that's when I'm working.
是的，那是怎么回事，你当时在出版社工作，还是，嗯，或者还在做其他说唱？在那个时候，嗯，就像在高中，或者？那是在高中。嗯，你知道，你开始，嗯，我10岁就开始工作了，我道歉。是的，是的，所以那就是我工作的时候。
Let me tell you something. Jason was supporting a family of eight by the time he was six. Okay, so he's not a good, they were like, Jason, go and act up on set, so they'll have to go into overtime, okay? You've seen Oliver Twist, yeah. Wait, so Aquafina and, and, and Nora Lum, which is, you know, it's fascinating that you created the name Aquafina.
让我告诉你一件事。杰森在六岁的时候就在养活一个八口之家。好的，所以他不是一个好，他们就像，杰森，去片场表演，这样他们就得加班，好吗？你看过《雾都孤儿》，是的。等等，所以奥卡菲娜和，和，和诺拉·卢姆，也就是，你知道，你创造了奥卡菲娜这个名字，这很迷人。
For people who don't know, just explain where the name comes from. I've always been kind of very awkward. So it was, it's kind of a play on that, but they're really, you know, there's no story. I just thought it was, um. Aquafina. Ridiculous. Yeah. And then what's finer than being awkward.
对于不知道的人，解释一下这个名字的由来。我一直都很尴尬。所以它，它有点像那个的文字游戏，但它们真的，你知道，没有故事。我只是觉得它是，嗯。奥卡菲娜。荒谬。是的。还有什么比尴尬更美好的呢。
Right, right. There you go. And what determines how you'll introduce yourself between Nora and Aquafina? Like, and when you're 95, will the nursing home call you Aquafina? I'm going to make them all call me Aquafina. Be like one of those situations. But, uh, I don't know. I think, um, you know, they're both obviously like a part of me. It's, it's a difficult situation.
对，对。就是这样。什么决定了你会在诺拉和奥卡菲娜之间如何介绍自己？比如，当你95岁的时候，疗养院会叫你奥卡菲娜吗？我会让他们都叫我奥卡菲娜。就像那种情况之一。但是，嗯，我不知道。我想，嗯，你知道，它们显然都是我的一部分。这是一个，这是一个困难的情况。
I think, um, I'm not really at the point in my career where I can suddenly go by another name and people will kind of put that together. Right. What does your best friend call you? Um, I make them call me Aquafina. Uh, they, no, no, they call me Nora. They do? Yeah. They call me Nora. Yeah. Oh really? No one ever, they ever go Aqua for short?
我想，嗯，我真的还没到我职业生涯的那个阶段，我可以突然换个名字，人们会把它们联系起来。对。你最好的朋友叫你什么？嗯，我让他们叫我奥卡菲娜。嗯，他们，不，不，他们叫我诺拉。他们叫吗？是的。他们叫我诺拉。是的。哦，真的吗？从来没有人，他们有没有叫过Aqua作为简称？
Yeah. Or Q? Some people, yeah. Some people will just, you know, throw their own, not Q, but they'll throw their own pizzazz in there. Right. It's, uh, it's good. When you were growing up, you had a restaurant, your, your dad or your mom or your dad's Chinese, your mom's Korean.
是的。或者Q？有些人，是的。有些人会只是，你知道，加入他们自己的，不是Q，但他们会加入他们自己的活力。对。它，它很好。当你长大的时候，你有一个餐馆，你的，你爸爸或者你妈妈或者你爸爸是中国人，你妈妈是韩国人。
Right. And who was it that owned the restaurant? My great grandpa. Oh, your great grandpa. Yeah. And how cool was that? Like, there was a lumps in my hometown. I can't imagine that was the same one. Where?
对。是谁拥有那个餐馆？我的曾祖父。哦，你的曾祖父。是的。那有多酷？就像，在我家乡有卢姆一家。我无法想象那是同一个。在哪里？
Glenna, Ellen, Illinois. Yeah. Did you enjoy it? No, no, we'll keep it in. Yeah, good question. Did you enjoy it, Sean? We never had the money to go. It was like a fancy restaurant. Here we go again.
伊利诺伊州的格伦纳，艾伦。是的。你喜欢吗？不，不，我们会保留它。是的，好问题。你喜欢吗，肖恩？我们从来没有钱去。那是一家高档餐馆。我们又来了。
Buckle up everybody. Get the violin. You play horn, I'll play violin. Uh, so, uh, Aquafina, sweet Nora. It's my daughter's middle name. I do love that name. Oh, that's good. Yeah. Not a lot of noras.
大家系好安全带。拿小提琴来。你吹号，我拉小提琴。嗯，所以，嗯，奥卡菲娜，可爱的诺拉。这是我女儿的中间名。我确实喜欢那个名字。哦，那很好。是的。诺拉不多。
Oh, here we go. My dad left when I was about five and your mom left in a different way. She passed away when you were four. Yeah. So, a question I get a lot, which I like is how has that informed you
哦，我们来了。我爸爸在我大约五岁的时候离开了，你妈妈以不同的方式离开了。她在你四岁的时候去世了。是的。所以，我经常得到的一个问题，我喜欢的是，那如何影响了你
or your relationships or your work? Do you think that's informed you or affected you in what way? Uh, yeah. There's a softball. Yeah, yeah, it's starting to be easy. I'll give you an answer to this. Nice, Sean.
或者你的人际关系或者你的工作？你认为那影响了你或者以什么方式影响了你？嗯，是的。这是一个软球。是的，是的，开始变得容易了。我会给你一个答案。不错，肖恩。
And a great transition too, Sean. Yeah, I'll give you guys a cliff-nosed version. Let's see, I'm asking these things I wouldn't, I want to know. Yeah. Because it affected me. Nah, I mean, it's a, it's a legit question. I think, um, I think it's, uh, taught me things like
而且是一个很好的过渡，肖恩。是的，我会给你们一个简短的版本。让我们看看，我问这些我不会，我想知道。是的。因为它影响了我。不，我是说，这是一个，这是一个合法的问题。我想，嗯，我想它是，呃，教会了我一些事情，比如
humility, embarrassment, the feeling of being embarrassed for like adults, which is, is like a kind of a weird feeling, uh, to feel as a kid almost protecting adults for their own sorrow. Um, so like learning that.
谦逊，尴尬，为成年人感到尴尬的感觉，这，是，像一种奇怪的感觉，呃，作为一个孩子几乎保护成年人免受他们自己的悲伤。嗯，所以就像学习那个。
But then, I think that, uh, it teaches you something about, um, just kind of like cruel realism about life. This is kind of like the cruelty of, of, and, and objectiveness of life. It's not, it just teaches you those lessons really young. And I think as a result,
但是然后，我想，呃，它教会了你关于，嗯，只是那种关于生活的残酷现实。这有点像那种残酷的，和，和生活的客观性。它不是，它只是在很小的时候就教会了你那些教训。而且我想结果是，
you know, you can say that some develop humor out of it. Yeah, yeah. It's, uh, the ability to, you know, in those times see humor also, because I mean, how bad, how bad worse could it get? Right. And strength too, probably, right? A thicker skin. Yeah. Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
你知道，你可以说有些人从中发展出了幽默感。是的，是的。它是，呃，能力，你知道，在那些时候看到幽默，因为我是说，还能有多糟糕？对。还有力量，可能吧，对吧？更厚的皮肤。是的。是的，这就是我要说的。
Did it give you that sort of that ability of like, fuck it. I mean, I've already been through so much I can handle anything. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, sure. I think it makes you tough, but I think for others, I think that there could be kind of not really good coping mechanisms. You know, we kind of, uh,
它给了你那种能力，比如，去他的。我是说，我已经经历了很多，我可以处理任何事情。是的。是的。是的，当然。我想它让你变得坚强，但我认为对其他人来说，我认为可能有一些不是很好的应对机制。你知道，我们有点，呃，
swallow it down so it comes up later in life, you know. But I think kids are a lot better at dealing with trauma than adults. I think they have a easier way of just shutting it off. But, you know, I also, I do believe that the best comedians do go through some
把它吞下去，所以它在以后的生活中会出现，你知道。但我认为孩子们比成年人更擅长处理创伤。我认为他们有一种更容易的方式来关闭它。但是，你知道，我也，我确实相信最好的喜剧演员确实经历过一些
kind of, through something, you know? Yeah. I mean, how do you think it's shaped you, Sean? Almost exactly the same way. It made me, well, you know, my dad you know, left when I was about five and my mom raised all of us, but she was never around so it forced us to parent ourselves. How many siblings did you have?
某种，经历过一些事情，你知道？是的。我是说，你认为它如何塑造了你，肖恩？几乎完全一样的方式。它让我，嗯，你知道，我爸爸你知道，在我大约五岁的时候离开了，我妈妈抚养了我们所有人，但她从来不在身边，所以它迫使我们自己抚养自己。你有多少个兄弟姐妹？
Five. I have three older brothers and an older sister. And so, but it, um, yeah, it made me, it's fight or flight kind of feeling, you know, and, uh, and if, when you choose to fight, it's sometimes your best quality and sometimes your worst quality. Yeah. And, um,
五个。我有三个哥哥和一个姐姐。所以，但是它，嗯，是的，它让我，它是战斗或逃跑的那种感觉，你知道，而且，呃，而且如果你，当你选择战斗时，它有时是你最好的品质，有时是你最坏的品质。是的。而且，嗯，
and so both come out even to this day, you know, uh, Jason can attest to that. About the coming out? No, about the, uh, because that's what it sounded like you were saying. Okay, sure. I'm not ready to make an announcement on the podcast. Um, so, um,
所以两者甚至到今天都会出现，你知道，呃，杰森可以证明这一点。关于出来？不，关于，呃，因为那听起来像是你在说的。好的，当然。我还没准备好在播客上宣布。嗯，所以，嗯，
It's not his place. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I get that. You know, one time when I was a kid, oh boy, and I haven't shared this. Oh shit. Here we go. A little bit of a music change. Get the audience ready to laugh. Yeah. One time we were supposed to go to, um, St. Bart's for spring break.
这不是他的位置。是的。是的。是的。我明白了。你知道，有一次当我还是个孩子的时候，哦男孩，我还没分享过这个。哦该死。我们来了。一点音乐变化。让观众准备好笑。是的。有一次我们应该去，嗯，圣巴特岛过春假。
And, uh, there was no more room in first class. You guys had to fly in class. Oh man. Yeah, that's tough. How did that affect you? And, uh, and I've always been able to look back on that and reach for that. Sure. Yeah. You know, every time that's so beautiful. Every time I'm booking a flight.
而且，呃，头等舱没有更多空间了。你们不得不坐经济舱。哦，伙计。是的，那很艰难。那对你有什么影响？而且，呃，而且我一直能够回顾那个并伸手去拿那个。当然。是的。你知道，每次那太美了。每次我预订航班。
No, no, not in my career. I'm just saying every time I book a flight, I always think about that book an extra seat. So in case what did you think I was? This is insane. Sorry. No, I'm with you now. But I will say, so Akofi, I don't know about your experience, but Sean, you do
不，不，不是在我的职业生涯中。我只是说每次我预订航班，我总是想到那个预订一个额外的座位。所以以防万一你以为我是什么？这太疯狂了。抱歉。不，我现在和你在一起。但我会说，所以奥卡菲娜，我不知道你的经历，但肖恩，你确实
you do talk a lot about your family and your origin and all of that and your upbringing. It is such a huge part of obviously of who you've become and all of us do. Jason, you talk about it too. We laugh about you being a child and we all do have
你确实谈论了很多关于你的家庭和你的出身以及所有这些以及你的成长经历。这显然是你成为谁的巨大一部分，我们所有人都是。杰森，你也谈论它。我们嘲笑你作为一个孩子，我们确实都有
our own experiences and you're younger than we are. Can you feel like you're in it right now and can you feel yourself drawing on those experiences like as it's happening? Because I feel like I reflect now more, I guess because I'm getting older. Well, you also got
我们自己的经历，而且你比我们年轻。你能感觉到你现在就在其中吗？你能感觉到自己在事情发生时利用那些经历吗？因为我觉得我现在反思更多，我想是因为我变老了。好吧，你也得到了
those two boys, three boys wait, four. Four total. Four boys running. Three boys in a step son. So that's a mirror in front of you all the time and Sean and Akofi, do you guys having sort of a challenging
那两个男孩，三个男孩等等，四个。总共四个。四个男孩在跑。三个男孩和一个继子。所以那是一面镜子一直在你面前，肖恩和奥卡菲娜，你们有某种具有挑战性的
upbringing or an atypical upbringing, does it make you more or less want to be a parent? I was going to ask the same thing especially with the loss of your mom at such a young age, does it make you want to be a mom? I mean it gives me more
成长经历或非典型的成长经历，这让你更想还是更不想成为父母？我本来要问同样的事情，特别是你在这么小的年纪失去妈妈，这让你想成为妈妈吗？我是说它给了我更多
trepidation about what that experience might be like, I think. That's fair. I think the funny thing about success and doing what you're able to do that seems like a gift because what we do is
关于那种经历可能是什么样的忧虑，我想。这很公平。我想关于成功和做你能够做的事情的有趣之处在于，这看起来像是一份礼物，因为我们所做的是
we're so lucky to be able to do what we do and I think when you enter that you forget a lot about your childhood and the things that you grew up kind of missing or being resentful over and then I think you convince yourself it's all good I'm successful, this is great
我们非常幸运能够做我们所做的事情，而且我想当你进入那个阶段时，你会忘记很多关于你的童年以及你成长过程中错过或怨恨的事情，然后我想你会说服自己一切都好，我很成功，这太棒了
but then it will come back and it'll be, for me it's like now at a point where I don't want it to be crippling, you know what I mean? So it's like things come back for sure. This is going to sound like a crazy question
但然后它会回来，它会是，对我来说就像现在到了一个我不希望它变得瘫痪的地步，你明白我的意思吗？所以就像事情肯定会回来。这听起来像是一个疯狂的问题
but because I don't want to have kids and from the answer you just gave it kind of sounds like you're more leaning towards that so then are you an animal person? Like do you dog's cats and all that? Or no? Yeah, I have a cat in that house, yeah. Okay, take care.
但因为我不想有孩子，从你刚才给出的答案来看，听起来你更倾向于那个，所以你是动物爱好者吗？比如狗、猫之类的？还是不？是的，我在那个房子里有一只猫，是的。好的，保重。
You don't like cats? No, I like cats. I'm a huge, huge, huge dog. Oh. But I like cats. Do you get to travel with them? No, they don't want to come with me. Yeah. But you'll travel with your cat, I'm hearing, yeah?
你不喜欢猫？不，我喜欢猫。我是一个巨大、巨大、巨大的狗。哦。但我喜欢猫。你有机会带它们旅行吗？不，它们不想跟我来。是的。但我听说你会带你的猫旅行，是的？
Once, yeah. We had given him like cat Xanax but he's like 35 pounds so... Do you have any leftover? No, it's a long gone. You've got a mountain lion at 35 pounds. He's a big boy. He's very, very large
有一次，是的。我们给了它像猫用的安定，但它有35磅重，所以……你有剩下的吗？不，早就没了。你有一只35磅重的山狮。它是一个大男孩。它非常、非常大
and so we, he gave him the cat Xanax and on the flight his eyes were wide open and then he like, I was like, oh, is he sleeping now? Wide open and then he had shat and it was
所以我们，他给了它猫用的安定，在飞行中它的眼睛睁得大大的，然后它就像，我当时想，哦，它现在在睡觉吗？睁得大大的，然后它拉了，而且它是
it was miserable. It was miserable. Wait a minute. He shat in his cage. He had shat in his carrier because we didn't give him food so the Xanax would hit harder but then we gave it the Xanax to him in a treat and when we did
它是悲惨的。它是悲惨的。等等。它在笼子里拉了。它在它的航空箱里拉了，因为我们没有给它食物，所以安定会起作用，但然后我们把安定放在零食里给它，当我们这样做的时候
all of his treats came out so he basically ate all of his treats and then pooped on the plane. When they come out, they're not treats. I will say that. It's just normal. I had a next girlfriend once we traveled with the cat, same thing happened and I just
它所有的零食都出来了，所以它基本上吃了它所有的零食，然后在飞机上拉了。当它们出来的时候，它们不是零食。我会说那一点。它只是正常的。我曾经有一个前女友，我们带着猫旅行，同样的事情发生了，我只是
I'd swap seats with somebody else. You just give up at some point. It's terrible. All right, so then Aquafina between music and acting and comedy stand up and all that. Would you ideally like to continue
我和别人换了座位。你只是在某个时候放弃了。这太可怕了。好吧，那么奥卡菲娜，在音乐、表演和喜剧单口相声和所有这些之间。你理想中想继续
sort of a blend of all those things or would you like to transition to kind of have one dominate your career? I never really had a plan. Music is something that I do all the time. What's what I like doing is making beats, making music and stuff so that'll never leave
某种所有这些东西的混合，还是你想过渡到让其中一个主导你的职业生涯？我从来没有真正的计划。音乐是我一直做的事情。我喜欢做的是制作节拍，制作音乐之类的，所以那永远不会离开
but I think I don't really know about the other stuff. I feel like you were about to say music's my passion. You backed off it and said it's what I like to do. Is that true? Yeah, it is true because then I heard myself that and I thought about the tattoo that I have.
但我认为我真的不知道其他东西。我觉得你刚才要说音乐是我的激情。你退缩了，说这是我喜欢做的事情。是真的吗？是的，是真的，因为然后我听到了自己那样说，我想到了我有的纹身。
Passion is a tough word coming out, yeah. Believe me, I know that feeling. I'd say it all the time because Jason always describes himself as an artist and I was like gross, dude. Gross. Guys, I just like to tell stories, you know, just a storyteller. He has a big comedy tragedy masks on his back tattoo.
激情是一个很难说出口的词，是的。相信我，我知道那种感觉。我一直那样说，因为杰森总是形容自己是一个艺术家，我当时想，恶心，伙计。恶心。伙计们，我只是喜欢讲故事，你知道，只是一个讲故事的人。他背上有巨大的喜剧悲剧面具纹身。
He can't tell the difference between them apparently. I had a director tell me one time and he'll probably listen to this and know it's him and then he'll but he's never hired me anyway, so what the hell do I care? And he said, you know, and I decided somebody said to me, you're a storyteller.
他显然分不清它们。有一次一位导演告诉我，他可能会听这个并知道是他，然后他会，但他从来没有雇过我，所以我在乎什么？他说，你知道，我决定有人对我说，你是一个讲故事的人。
You need to be telling stories and I'm like, excuse me, one second, I've got to barf everything I've ever eaten in my life. There's always a friend that tells you that when they've given up on advice to give you and that's like how they'll end it.
你需要讲故事，我当时想，对不起，一秒钟，我得吐出我一生中吃过的所有东西。总有一个朋友会在他们放弃给你建议时告诉你，那就是他们结束的方式。
So if you're a storyteller, you just tell stories. Okay, I got it. But it's fair to say that music is, you are passionate about your music. That's okay. I am because I had to like really learn like music and spend a lot of hours like
所以如果你是一个讲故事的人，你就讲故事。好的，我明白了。但公平地说，音乐是，你对你的音乐充满激情。那没关系。我是，因为我不得不像真正学习音乐，并花费很多小时像
getting better at it and I guess it should be the same for acting but you know, that it just with comedy stuff, it's like I didn't have to, you know, study that. It just kind of is what it is. And so acting is obviously
变得更好，我想表演也应该一样，但你知道，那只是关于喜剧的东西，就像我不必，你知道，学习那个。它只是它是什么。所以表演显然是
what I'm getting is you kind of just fell into acting. You didn't really pursue it, kind of pursued you. I mean, is that I mean, it was a mutual I think, you know, but I mean, did you actively wake up ambitiously pursuing an acting career? No, no, not at all. I think
我得到的是你有点只是掉进了表演。你并没有真正追求它，它有点追求你。我是说，那是，我是说，我认为是相互的，你知道，但是我是说，你有没有积极地雄心勃勃地追求演艺事业？不，不，一点也没有。我想
I woke up ambitiously pursuing anything that would like pay rent. Right. Where are you finding most of your opportunities now? Is it acting or is it music? I mean, I haven't I haven't made music in a minute. I think I'm still kind of I have to find out like
我醒来时雄心勃勃地追求任何能付房租的东西。对。你现在在哪里找到大部分机会？是表演还是音乐？我是说，我还没，我还没做音乐有一会儿了。我想我仍然有点，我必须找出像
who I am now as an artist. I think that's been put on hold because I've been doing a lot. A lot of it is in movies and stuff right now. And are you happy with that? Is that where you want to keep it pointed? You said that you didn't really have a plan. Do you have a plan now or do you kind of like not
我现在作为一个艺术家是谁。我想那被搁置了，因为我一直在做很多事情。现在很多都在电影之类的东西里。你对那个满意吗？那是你想保持它的方向吗？你说你真的没有计划。你现在有计划吗，还是你有点喜欢
having a plan and things seem to be working out great, not having a plan or being overly strategic or anything like that. There's something to be said for that. For sure. I think it's a little bit of both. I really enjoy that. I enjoy making movies. It's
没有计划，事情似乎进展得很顺利，没有计划或者过于战略性之类的。那是有道理的。当然。我想两者都有点。我真的很喜欢那个。我喜欢制作电影。它是
what I love doing and it's cool because it affords me time to do music and to have that also. And so do you feel like being what politicians like to call a minority
我喜欢做的事情，而且很酷，因为它让我有时间做音乐，也有那个。所以你觉得作为政客喜欢称之为少数群体
and a woman and all of those things that you do feel like you have to approach everything from a place of I'll show you or are you like fuck it and I'm just going to enjoy it and that fight doesn't run that deep for you. You know what I mean?
和一个女人以及你所做的所有那些事情，你觉得你必须从一个“我会让你看看”的角度来处理一切，还是你就像去他的，我只是要享受它，那种战斗对你来说没有那么深。你明白我的意思吗？
There's not a lot of people like me that I grew up with and that's not even to say that to idolize but literally to see what happened with them. And I think in that way whatever we're doing right now
没有多少像我这样的人，我是在他们身边长大的，那甚至不是说要崇拜，而是字面上看看他们发生了什么。而且我认为以那种方式，无论我们现在在做什么
in the beginning you meet a person like me and you don't understand what kind of person that is and I think or what to do with that person or what to do with that person and as that person
在开始的时候，你遇到像我这样的人，你不明白那是什么样的人，而且我想或者对那个人做什么，或者对那个人做什么，而且作为那个人
if you don't have a roadmap of what has happened with other people you don't know and so in a lot of ways a lot of this generation of Asian-American and other minorities that are coming out right now they're pioneering something
如果你没有其他人发生什么的路线图，你不知道，所以以很多方式，这一代亚裔美国人和其他少数群体现在正在出来，他们正在开拓某种东西
and they're going to get all of that to make it easier for the next generations. And so do you feel like you have to be self-generating then? You have to create your own projects because they're not coming to you or? Well I think that's always every person should have a self-generating aspect to their work.
而且他们会得到所有这些，让下一代更容易。所以你觉得你必须是自我生成的吗？你必须创造你自己的项目，因为它们没有来找你，或者？好吧，我认为那总是每个人都应该有他们工作的自我生成方面。
You don't want to be the person that's like sitting around waiting for a call you want to be able to do that and you don't want to lose that but yeah I think as a minority it's that you just don't know what box you would fit into either. Right, right. So then what tell us about
你不想成为那种坐在那里等电话的人，你想能够做到这一点，而且你不想失去那个，但是是的，我认为作为一个少数群体，你只是不知道你会适合什么盒子。对，对。所以那么什么，告诉我们关于
your to the extent you're comfortable or interested about your experience being a minority in a place like New York City did you find it, did you feel fortunate that you were in a city that is as much of a melting pot as New York is I mean I imagine you didn't have anything to compare it to
在你舒适或感兴趣的范围内，关于你在像纽约市这样的地方作为少数群体的经历，你觉得幸运吗，因为你在一个像纽约这样的大熔炉城市，我是说我想象你没有什么可以比较的
but I would imagine it would be easier there than some other sort of you know less progressive place in the United States. The thing about New York City is you don't feel like the minority there because like I had trouble
但我会想象在那里比美国其他一些，你知道，不那么进步的地方更容易。关于纽约市的事情是你不会在那里感到是少数群体，因为就像我有麻烦
grasping xenophobia and certain kinds of things like that when I was a kid because how is that possible when the world looks like the way that it does and I also think that there is something about New York that forces you to grow up a little quicker
掌握仇外心理和某些那种事情，当我还是个孩子的时候，因为当世界看起来像那样的时候，那怎么可能？而且我也认为纽约有一些东西迫使你成长得更快
you know. So do you then feel that you were exposed to sort of that prejudice and that racism there that did you feel that xenophobia was present there or not present? Was that what you were saying? Xenophobia was definitely present through my childhood in terms of
你知道。所以你觉得你暴露在那种偏见和那种种族主义中了吗，你觉得仇外心理在那里存在还是不存在？那是你在说的吗？仇外心理在我的童年时期绝对存在，就
like I mean I think there was this Asian American writer that said Asian Americans are kind of united by the discrimination that they went through going up like a lot of Asian Americans are the Qing Zhang and like the thighs things and I grew up with that but
像，我是说我认为有一个亚裔美国作家说亚裔美国人有点被他们成长过程中经历的歧视所团结，就像很多亚裔美国人是清张和像大腿东西，我是在那个环境下长大的，但是
I also know that I would also like prove people wrong in the sense that I am not going to be the Asian girl that you think I am when I open my mouth when I start talking and so like you know when I have road rage for instance and they think they just you know I roll down
我也知道我也会像证明人们是错的，在这个意义上，我不会成为你认为我会成为的亚洲女孩，当我张开嘴，当我开始说话的时候，所以就像你知道，当我例如有路怒症时，他们认为他们只是，你知道，我摇下
my window and like start screaming and they're just like a look of horror and I think in that moment they're changed. I love that. It's just always a yeah. Do you feel pressure from the Asian American community then to be like a spokesperson for them and you know is that
我的窗户，然后开始尖叫，他们只是像一种恐惧的表情，而且我想在那一刻他们改变了。我喜欢那个。它总是，是的。你觉得来自亚裔美国社区的压力，要成为他们的发言人，而且你知道，那是
something you embrace or do you feel more like that it's an obligation or none of those things? I think when artists first start out they want to be themselves you know they want to be the artist, the storyteller you know but you owe something to your community regardless because you are representing them.
你拥抱的东西，还是你觉得更像是那是一种义务，或者都不是？我想当艺术家刚开始时，他们想成为他们自己，你知道，他们想成为艺术家，讲故事的人，你知道，但你无论如何都欠你的社区一些东西，因为你在代表他们。
Like I've said this I'll be on my deathbed and my dying breath will be I didn't want to represent Asians and I would still be representing them in that moment you know so it's like it's a responsibility that I take seriously. And they're like what's that Nora?
就像我说过这个，我会在我的临终床上，我临终的呼吸将是我不想代表亚洲人，而且我仍然会在那一刻代表他们，你知道，所以这就像一个我认真对待的责任。他们就像，那是诺拉吗？
And you're like call me Aquafina. I'm like it's Aquafina bitch. By the way go back to the rap thing because I think people who don't know you from that but know you from your movies and by the way I think I've seen every movie you've ever been in.
然后你就像，叫我奥卡菲娜。我就像，是奥卡菲娜，婊子。顺便说一句，回到说唱的事情，因为我认为那些不知道你从那，但从你的电影知道你的人，顺便说一句，我想我看过你演过的每一部电影。
Yeah I just think and the farewell you were just no wonder you won that Golden Globes. That was unbelievable incredible performance yeah just amazing. But going back to the rapping thing because a lot of people who you know you from movies like wait she was a rapper
是的，我只是认为，还有《别告诉她》，你只是，难怪你赢得了那个金球奖。那真是令人难以置信的表演，是的，真是太棒了。但回到说唱的事情，因为很多人，你知道，你从电影里认识，就像等等，她是说唱歌手
and what were your influences what made you want to get into rap like what was the person or the situation or the thing that you're like yeah that's really cool I'm really drawn to that. I mean I grew up in Queens listening to that and you know I had a love affair with it
而且你的影响是什么，是什么让你想进入说唱，就像是什么人或情况或事情，你就像，是的，那真的很酷，我真的很被那个吸引。我是说，我在皇后区长大，听那个，而且你知道，我有一段恋情
when I was growing up I worshiped DJ Herc Cool Herc you know DJ Rashad I loved producers J Dilla I was really into like the old MPCs the Akai's into that and when I was in high school
当我长大的时候，我崇拜DJ Herc Cool Herc，你知道，DJ Rashad，我喜欢制作人J Dilla，我真的很喜欢像旧的MPCs，Akai，喜欢那个，而且当我上高中的时候
and I think you know I was mentally depressed hip hop was a music that I loved and that spoke to me I listened to people under the stairs Tribe Called Quest and it was a genre that I loved and I think when it
而且我想你知道，我精神上很沮丧，嘻哈是我喜欢的音乐，而且它对我说话，我听了楼下的人，Tribe Called Quest，而且它是我喜欢的流派，而且我想当它
in terms of when it became like my vag and stuff I she said with a straight face I was making beats and you know I wanted to do a response to my dick I mean I you know to this day I still make beats
就当它变成像《My Vag》之类的东西时，她说，面无表情，我正在制作节拍，而且你知道，我想做一个对《My Dick》的回应，我是说，我，你知道，直到今天我仍然制作节拍
it's what I love. I love that I love that. What a sentence Yeah When it's read back in court it's going to be incredible What did she say? The stenographer is like my badge my dick
这是我喜欢的。我喜欢那个，我喜欢那个。什么句子，是的，当它在法庭上被读出来时，那将是令人难以置信的，她说了什么？速记员就像，我的徽章，我的迪克
so the fact that you are an Asian American raised by your grandmother who you've called your best friend which I love because I love my grandmother so much and taking the journey from America to China and then you get
所以你是一个由祖母抚养长大的亚裔美国人，你称她为最好的朋友，我喜欢这个，因为我非常爱我的祖母，而且从美国到中国的旅程，然后你得到
a script handed to you about that exact same thing called the farewell and you were amazing do you ever feel like do you ever feel like oh shit well that relationship between a girl and a grandmother is just a slice of who I am but I wonder if Hollywood is like
一个关于完全相同事情的剧本递给你，叫《别告诉她》，而且你很棒，你有没有觉得，你有没有觉得，哦该死，好吧，那个女孩和祖母之间的关系只是我的一部分，但我不知道好莱坞是否像
done with me now because that's the thing they see as my life offering you know do you feel like you now have to create your own things going forward And not just that when you read that were you prepped did you know what you were getting into or did you read it and go
现在完成了我，因为那是他们视为我生活奉献的东西，你知道，你觉得你现在必须创造你自己的东西前进？而且不仅如此，当你读到那个时，你准备好了吗，你知道你进入了什么，还是你读了它然后去
were you like holy shit holy shit holy shit as you went Yeah Sean you just brought up a really interesting point I didn't I never thought of it like that for me it felt like really auspicious that I couldn't believe that
你就像，该死，该死，该死，当你去的时候，是的，肖恩，你刚才提出了一个非常有趣的点，我没有，我从来没有那样想过，对我来说，这感觉真的很吉祥，我无法相信
this even exists and I definitely felt unprepared for it I knew that like this I've never done this before I just started acting right but I felt a connection to it and like this this kind of preconceived notion that I
这甚至存在，而且我绝对感到没有准备好，我知道像这个，我以前从来没有做过这个，我刚开始表演，对吧？但我感到一种联系，而且就像这个，这种先入为主的概念，我
could do this even though I don't think I have the skills right now I could because I feel I feel it right you know and it was one of those really rare things that's like you know the two connections it's like right because the thing that Hollywood loves to do is the second they find
可以做到这一点，即使我不认为我现在有技能，我可以，因为我感觉，我感觉到了，对吧，你知道，而且它是那种非常罕见的事情之一，就像，你知道，两个联系，它就像，对，因为好莱坞喜欢做的事情是他们找到的第二秒
especially if you're a minority Asian Latin African-American whatever it is and you find that thing they go oh they did that great let's find somebody else now because they check that box for life for them you know
特别是如果你是少数族裔，亚裔、拉丁裔、非裔美国人，无论是什么身份，当你找到了那个机会，他们会说“哦，他们表现得真棒，现在让我们去找别人吧”，因为对他们来说，你只是完成了那项任务，你懂的。
a lot of people who do their like you know their film of their life story okay well you can't top that so then and then the artist is left going like oh well how do I figure this out again in Hollywood like how do I figure out my new now to move forward with other
很多人在拍他们的人生故事电影，好吧，你无法超越那个高度，然后艺术家就会想，“哦，好吧，我在好莱坞该怎么继续呢？我该如何找到新的方向来推进其他……”
roles because a lot of those people will just see me as that one thing yeah yeah well do you like that part about acting the whole sort of concept of pretending to be different people does is that what excites you about about acting kind of morphing into different kinds of
角色，因为很多人只会把我视为那一种人。是的，是的，你喜欢表演中那种假装成不同人的概念吗？那种变身为不同类型角色的感觉让你感到兴奋吗？
characters yeah yeah I like that about it all of it and I think for this stuff that the farewell the kind of the heavier stuff it's it's a different it really is a trend I'm not going to sound like one of those assholes
是的，是的，我喜欢关于它的一切。我认为对于像《别告诉她》这样比较沉重的内容，这确实是一种不同的体验，这真的是一种趋势。我不想听起来像个混蛋，
but it is a transformative experience like it's like deeply emotional it does have to do with like your past a lot of those things are present in something that normally what I was doing was just you know straight comedy so there's an aspect of fun but there's not
但这确实是一种变革性的体验，它非常感性，确实与你的过去有关。很多东西都存在于我通常所做的纯喜剧中，所以它有有趣的一面，但没有……
kind of like that you know your insights are involved in it and so that was an interesting thing and there is something that's like holy shit is this am I going to is this really bad like is this horrible you know and all of those doubts and those fears which I
那种……你知道，你的洞察力被融入其中，所以这是一件有趣的事情。而且有一种感觉是，“天哪，这会很糟糕吗？这太可怕了吗？”你知道，所有那些怀疑和恐惧，我认为……
think you need you know yeah yeah for sure it helps it yeah and you know you just have accomplished so much so fast it seems like you're just a massively successful talented
你需要这些，是的，确实，它有帮助。而且你知道，你在这么短的时间内取得了如此多的成就，看起来你是一个非常成功、有才华的……
actor rapper writer producer what do you want to do what's left that you're like I still haven't conquered blank yeah where would you love to be in five years if you could if you could write it out I think photography you know really
演员、说唱歌手、编剧、制片人。你想做什么？还有什么是你觉得“我还没征服”的？是的，如果可以的话，五年后你想在哪里？如果你能写出来的话。我想是摄影，你知道，真的……
no we were ready oh you guys are so dumb I did not for the record I did not say really my my eyebrows are really high really that's so horrible but I will say this so like you and Sean's right
不，我们准备好了。哦，你们太笨了。郑重声明，我没说“真的”。我的眉毛挑得很高，“真的”，那太可怕了。但我会说，就像你和肖恩说的那样……
I mean you have done it's incredible it almost kind of makes your head spin how much you've done in such a short amount of time in so many different areas of the arts Nora from Queens you made that a couple did you make that a couple years ago five years ago
我的意思是，你所做的一切令人难以置信，你在艺术的这么多不同领域在如此短的时间内做了这么多事情，简直让人头晕目眩。《奥卡菲娜来自皇后区》，你几年前拍的？五年前？
five years ago is when we first yeah when you first did it and is that over now or are you continuing we're going into season two yeah you are we're going to make more and you like that experience making that show I do it's interesting
五年前是我们第一次……是的，你第一次做的时候。现在结束了吗？还是在继续？我们要拍第二季了。是的，你们要拍更多。你喜欢制作那部剧的经历吗？我喜欢，这很有趣。
it's my life and it was one of my first executive producer jobs so there's a lot involved with that obviously but yeah it's my own so it feels different so you're going into season two and it's your own and it feels very personal and
这是我的生活，也是我第一份执行制片人的工作之一，所以显然涉及很多事情。但是的，这是我自己的作品，所以感觉不同。所以你要拍第二季了，这是你自己的作品，感觉非常个人化，而且……
is that something you would want to keep making it do you see that five years that you're doing season five of Nora from Queens I I'm not counting that out I think everything has a natural course I'm not going to force people to watch something that no one wants to watch if that's the case
这是你想继续做下去的事情吗？你预见五年后你还在拍《奥卡菲娜来自皇后区》的第五季吗？我不会排除这种可能。我认为一切都有其自然的发展过程，如果没人想看，我不会强迫人们去看。
I will it's so great you're so great so Aquafita what are you an introvert like me where you've got your PJs on at four o'clock in the afternoon or do you like to what do you do today do you go out a lot
我会的。你太棒了，你太棒了。所以奥卡菲娜，你是像我一样的内向者吗？下午四点还穿着睡衣？还是你喜欢……你今天做什么？你经常出去吗？
or do you stay in and do a bunch of writing and a bunch of thinking and reading and what type of person are you in or out I mean well today I actually went to the Grove and I had Venice Beach went to a buffet come on no none of those
还是你待在家里写东西、思考、阅读？你是哪种人，外向还是内向？我的意思是，今天我去了格罗夫购物中心，去了威尼斯海滩，还去吃了自助餐。得了吧，没有……
things are allowed I'm an extrovert and introvert I felt I definitely went crazy a little bit in this thing I realized I probably am not the person that I'd want to be quarantined with you don't like being inside all the time
那些事情是不被允许的。我是外向者也是内向者。我确实在这件事上有点疯了。我意识到我可能不是那种我想一起隔离的人。你不喜欢一直待在室内吗？
you like to get out and socialize because that's what essentially it is yeah I like to stay at home and and watch movies and stuff oh I like that I actually just saw you remember Love Stinks Jason
你喜欢出去社交，因为本质上就是这样。是的，我喜欢待在家里看电影之类的。哦，我喜欢那个。我其实刚看了……你记得《爱情臭屁》吗，杰森？
oh god what are you doing here's that we do need things to cut out this is good keep going okay okay yeah where this part can go oh man this is I know a lot of weird
哦天哪，你在做什么？我们需要剪掉这段，这很好，继续。好的，好的，是的，这一部分可以……哦天哪，我知道很多关于那部电影的奇怪……
facts about that movie because I owned it growing up and I had the director's cut so I actually literally listened to Bridget Wilson and the director do the director's cut talking about all the little gaffes like there was like this bottle of liquor that was always there I know weird things about that movie I've seen
事实，因为我从小就拥有它，而且我有导演剪辑版。所以我实际上听了布里奇特·威尔逊和导演做的导演剪辑版评论，谈论所有的小失误，比如总是有那一瓶酒。我知道关于那部电影的奇怪事情，我看过……
that movie thousands of times are you kidding me yeah french Stewart man Chris I love that movie come on a little it's a little it doesn't age well for sure and I had this big stupid long sheep hurt her hair it was lit you were awesome with a Hawaiian
那部电影几千遍了，你在开玩笑吗？是的，弗伦奇·斯图尔特，伙计。克里斯，我喜欢那部电影，得了吧。它有点……它确实不太经得起时间考验。我当时留着那种又蠢又长的牧羊犬发型，你当时穿着夏威夷衬衫还是什么的，你太棒了。
shirt or something guys it's a it's a real treat to take a look at it's really I'll take it I'll check that out Jason shines it's yeah it should be known that I have Jason knows this I have a pristine copy of Teen Wolf 2 on DVD at my house
伙计们，看一看真是一种享受。真的，我会接受的，我会去看看的。杰森，它……应该知道我——杰森知道这一点——我家有一份《狼人2》的原始DVD拷贝。
and for some reason I've showed you some reason I was I was Teen Wolf 2 but it's Teen Wolf TOO it's Teen Wolf also it's not a sequel god damn it no he's a Teen Wolf 2 and
出于某种原因，我向你展示过……出于某种原因，我是《狼人2》，但它是《狼人TOO》，它不是续集，该死的。不，他是《狼人2》，而且……
so I have this copy as well it's on my dresser and for some reason it's on my dresser so I look at it every day why I see this I don't know why don't you change your dresser do it move stuff around for Christ's sake
所以我也有这份拷贝，它在我的梳妆台上，出于某种原因它就在那儿，所以我每天都看它。为什么？我看到这个……我不知道。你为什么不换个梳妆台？为了上帝的缘故，把东西挪一挪。
Aquafina you've not seen Teen Wolf 2 she's not aware if you've seen Teen Wolf 1 she's very young Aquafina we used to play in a card game and Shawn used to play in it too the three of us used to this is we're going back a while now at least 15 years we used to play Tuesday nights
奥卡菲娜，你没看过《狼人2》？她不知道。如果你看过《狼人1》，她还很年轻。奥卡菲娜，我们过去常玩纸牌游戏，肖恩也常玩。我们三个过去常……这是很久以前的事了，至少15年前，我们过去常在周二晚上玩。
at this guy Kyle Gass's house oh well you know Tenacious oh you know Kyle it's Kyle Gass and Jack Black's yeah so Shawn actually Shawn if you remember Shawn came in the first night and did really well like one like just like oh man
在这个叫凯尔·加斯的人家里。哦，你知道“顽强之D”……哦，你知道凯尔。那是凯尔·加斯和杰克·布莱克的……是的，所以肖恩，实际上肖恩，如果你记得的话，肖恩第一晚就来了，表现得非常好，就像……哦天哪。
he just kept going down and he won and then he never won again like the worst thing you could do he didn't really come back that often did he after that he just took his winnings he started losing he was like I'm just losing like Texas Holden is poker and so this is like 15 years ago so
他一直赢，然后就再也没赢过。你能做的最糟糕的事情就是……他后来没怎么来了，对吧？在那之后，他拿了奖金，就开始输了。他说“我一直在输”，就像德州扑克一样。所以这是15年前的事了，所以……
so then but Kyle gave Jason the name of T-Dub T-Dub and every time the bet was to Jason or anything Kyle they knew each other Kyle would go T-Dub you win
然后，凯尔给了杰森一个绰号叫“T-Dub”。T-Dub，每次轮到杰森下注或者什么，凯尔——他们互相认识——凯尔就会说“T-Dub，你赢了”。
I miss playing cards so much I know that was fun wasn't that fun let's talk about the weed so you like to smoke joints smoke bongs chew on gummies or a little combination of each sorry one second before you answer that Aquafina just know Jason nobody's smoking
我太怀念打牌了。我知道，那很有趣，不是吗？我们来谈谈大麻。你喜欢抽卷烟、抽水烟筒、嚼软糖，还是每种都来一点？抱歉，等一下，在你回答之前，奥卡菲娜，你要知道，杰森，没人再抽……
bongs anymore this is 79 it's not fast times wait a second now in my youth there was a real ceremony buying a new bong about every
水烟筒了。这是79年吗？这不是《开放的美国学府》。等一下，在我年轻的时候，每隔三周买一个新的水烟筒是一种真正的仪式。
three weeks me and the fellas every three weeks it was so fun those big huge like hundred dollar bongs with five chambers and let's chop up some ice and oh so are you
我和伙计们，每三周一次，太有趣了。那些价值一百美元的大型水烟筒，有五个腔室，让我们切点冰块，哦……所以你在……
ripping bongs Aquafina no you have a bong in that house right now I guarantee you do there's a bong in the house stupid will now are you using that bong I've been using a volcano see that's a whole new level
抽水烟筒吗，奥卡菲娜？不。你现在家里有一个水烟筒，我保证你有。家里有一个水烟筒，笨蛋。好吧，现在你在用那个水烟筒吗？我一直在用火山雾化器。看，那是一个全新的水平。
what is that it's made by this German brand and it's called stores and bickle this brand and it's in a volcano and then you take this plastic bag and it vaporizes all of the things and then
那是什么？它是由这个德国品牌制造的，叫Storz & Bickel，这个品牌，它是一个火山雾化器，然后你拿这个塑料袋，它把所有的东西都雾化，然后……
you put the plastic bag over your head think about your life a little bit exactly cry bag over your head so the bag expands with smoke and then you throw your face inside the bag
你把塑料袋套在头上，稍微思考一下你的人生。完全正确，哭吧，袋子套在头上。所以袋子里充满了烟雾，然后你把脸伸进袋子里。
or do you make a little hole there's like an actual it looks like the top of a water bottle and what they call it is it's weed on tap so so when the volcano is not available your next best stop is
还是你挖个小洞？它看起来像个水瓶盖。他们称之为“随取随用的大麻”。所以当火山雾化器没电时，你的下一个最佳选择是……
you like to roll your own joints you consider yourself a good joint roller tinctures usually that's like an oil guys what is a tincture it's just like a little droplet of it's like an oil like a little dropper
你喜欢自己卷烟吗？你认为自己是个好的卷烟手吗？酊剂，通常那是油。伙计们，什么是酊剂？它就像一小滴……它就像油，像个小滴管。
put it under your tongue it's a terrible name Jason is fascinated with how people consume their weed and he always asks first of all bongs and secondly he wants to know if people are rolling does he open with the bongs? and then he wants to know who's rolling
放在舌头下面。这名字真糟糕。杰森对人们如何消费大麻很着迷，他总是问，首先是水烟筒，其次他想知道人们是否在卷烟。他开场就问水烟筒吗？然后他想知道谁在卷……
their own joints well that's something I used to love I used to love to roll I consider myself a very good joint roller and I do enjoy a bong I think the bongs are pretty amazing they will get kicked over
他们自己的烟。好吧，那是我过去喜欢做的事。我过去很喜欢卷烟，我认为自己是个非常好的卷烟手，我也喜欢水烟筒。我认为水烟筒相当棒，它们会被……
by the guy who smoked a little too much so you gotta put it up on the table don't put it on the floor you're a great parent put that on the table now the benefit of a bong because I think I did one once a long time ago you just need one hit and that's
那个抽得有点多的人踢翻。所以你得把它放在桌子上，别放在地板上。你是个伟大的家长，把它放在桌子上。现在，水烟筒的好处是——因为我想我很久以前用过一次——你只需要吸一口，然后……
you're good, you're good to go for a long time well the water cools the smoke so it's smoother I think you can inhale a lot what's that doctor excuse us everybody quiet in the back look at the scientist
你就好了，你可以保持很长时间。好吧，水冷却了烟雾，所以它更顺滑。我认为你可以吸入很多。那是谁？医生，原谅我们，大家安静，后面的人。看看这位科学家……
here what I need you to do you need to go and smoke weed with Sean because Sean is like a one hit wonder he takes half a hit of weed and he is calls his mom immediately
在这里。我需要你做的是，你需要去和肖恩一起抽大麻，因为肖恩就像个“一口倒”。他吸半口大麻，然后立刻给他妈妈打电话。
he's been dead for years great, dead mom jokes well that's awesome at the beginning of the podcast I stole his joke breathe the room that's a joke there's never been a better topic
他已经去世多年了。太棒了，死去的妈妈笑话。好吧，那太棒了。在播客开始时，我偷了他的笑话。让气氛缓和一下，那是个笑话。从来没有比大麻更好的话题……
to end on than weed let's do it I'm down, let's do it Sean you don't have to ask me twice I'm so down for that and by the way perfect way to kill quarantine time but I'm so happy and we are so happy
来结束了。我们开始吧，我准备好了，我们开始吧。肖恩，你不用问我两次，我非常乐意。顺便说一句，这是消磨隔离时间的完美方式。但我很高兴，我们很高兴……
to finally meet you it's been so, so, so long thanks, same Sean thank you thank you for representing an underserved and overlooked minority in this country and doing it in such a beautiful, thoughtful
终于见到你了。这真是太久太久了。谢谢，我也是，肖恩。谢谢你，谢谢你代表了这个国家一个服务不足和被忽视的少数群体，并以如此美丽、体贴、……
funny, talented way so you're just brilliant thanks Sean, really nice to meet you guys I want to get a little too high and watch Love Stinks with you and get a little paranoid and secure we can rip a bong that's nice
有趣、有才华的方式做到这一点。所以你真是太聪明了。谢谢肖恩，真的很高兴见到你们。我想稍微嗨一点，和你们一起看《爱情臭屁》，变得有点偏执和不安。我们可以抽个水烟筒，那很好。
I love watching young people be nice to a boomer it's great to meet you Aquafina and thank you for saying yes to sitting and talking with us bye honey bye guys you guys embarrassed me
我喜欢看年轻人对婴儿潮一代友好。很高兴见到你，奥卡菲娜，谢谢你答应坐下来和我们聊天。再见，亲爱的。再见，伙计们。你们让我尴尬了。
you guys embarrassed me what a nice charming and funny and kind yeah, no, she's great and by the way unless I got it wrong, we'll fact check it but I think to be the first
你们让我尴尬了。多么迷人、有趣和善良的人。是的，不，她很棒。顺便说一句，除非我弄错了——我们会核实一下——但我认为她是第一位……
Asian American lead actress to ever win a Golden Globe ever? that's crazy and to have so quickly have her star rise and to watch it, I feel like I'm watching myself she's got this big show
获得金球奖的亚裔美国女主角？这太疯狂了。看着她的明星之路如此迅速地崛起，我感觉就像在看我自己。她有这个大节目，……
she's got all this stuff going on and I follow her on Instagram she's constantly working and you'd think watching a film like Love Stinks would have torpedoed any sort of creative instinct she had going forward but she's so strong she can watch stuff like that and a performance by me like that
她有所有这些事情在进行，我在Instagram上关注她，她一直在工作。你会认为看像《爱情臭屁》这样的电影会摧毁她未来所有的创造本能，但她太强大了，她能看那样的东西，还有我那样的表演，……
and still carry on and deliver Golden Globe quality work you know? what year was Love Stinks? I don't remember, I poured cement over the whole no I think it was maybe early 90s I gotta check
还能继续前进，并交付金球奖质量的作品，你知道吗？《爱情臭屁》是哪一年的？我不记得了，我把一切都……不，我想可能是90年代初，我得查一下。
anyway, it was fun it's fun to look at like any old pictures when I say pictures, I don't mean films I mean like photos you will not refer to films as pictures if you ever hear me say I did a wonderful picture
总之，这很有趣。看旧照片很有趣。当我说是照片时，我指的不是电影，我指的是照片。如果你听到我说“我拍了一部精彩的照片”，你绝不能把电影称为照片。
it touched me hard in the face we were working on a picture and I'm going to ways back now what about when you say oh we did a wonderful wrote a wonderful piece we did it in a great space or the other way sometimes when you hear
它重重地打在我的脸上。我们当时正在拍一部电影，我现在要回溯一下。当你说是“哦，我们写了一部精彩的作品，我们在一个很棒的空间里完成了它”时，或者有时当你听到……
there are certain affected American actors who go well of course for me the cinema is like hey man you lived in Paris for 18 months fuck off hey what kind of science classes did you guys take in high school did anybody take like
有些做作的美国演员说“嗯，当然，对我来说，电影就像……嘿伙计，你在巴黎住了18个月，滚开”。嘿，你们高中上过什么科学课？有人上过……
chemistry or what hang on a second I gotta put my neck in traction bye melody oh melody smart wise smart
化学课什么的吗？等一下，我得把我的脖子放进牵引器里。再见，梅洛迪。哦，梅洛迪，聪明，睿智，聪明。
music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。